queerness fundamentally exists in
opposition to arguably the most
prevailing system in the human condition
which is heterosexual reproduction in
fact the dna of queerness is suspicion
or outright rejection of norms
orthodoxy and continuation scenarios
because norms and continuation typically
kept us miserable
or dead for millennia a default to
question the unquestionable is a strong
foundation
to readily envision transformative
alternatives and original ways of doing
and being jose esteban munoz wrote
cruising utopia just as the light at the
end of the tunnel was shining
towards the end of the aids epidemic and
we could begin to see queerness again
for for its positivity and for its
hopefulness and he wrote
queerness is essentially about the
rejection of a here now and an
insistence on potentiality or concrete
possibility
for another world and this is an
infamous pamphlet that was passed out
by act up in the 1990 new york a pride
parade
being queer means leading a different
sort of life it's not about the
mainstream profit margins patriotism
patriarchy or being assimilated
it's not about executive directors
privilege and elitism it's about being
on the margins
defining ourselves well many of us first
heard of
prison and police abolition this summer
with many of the black lives matter
riots
um resisting and questioning the
dominant systems of
of police and incarceration in the
cultural state have long been in the dna
of queerness itself
going all the way back to the 1966
compton's cafeteria riots here in san
francisco
or three years later at the root of the
stonewall riots which was an anti-police
demonstration
and as noted activist dr angela davis
has pointed out as
is true for so much of queer history it
was transgender people who actually
pointed the way
to this resistance dr davis says we
support the trans community precisely
because the trans community has taught
us how to challenge that which is
totally accepted as normal
if it is possible to challenge the
gender binary we can certainly
effectively resist
prisons and police